harrison ford is back in the spotlight  with the force awakens but he'll be  reprising another iconic role very soon  i'm tony and this gamespot news update  belongs in a museum the fifth Indiana  Jones movie is coming in 2019 Harrison  Ford will be playing India of course and  director Steven Spielberg will be  guiding the project like usual he  already directed the previous four  movies we haven't heard about any other  casting decisions or the movie's title  though it is pretty interesting to note  that Harrison Ford will be 77 when the  film opens prepare yourself for plenty  of jokes about Ford being old enough to  be in a museum himself the fifth Indiana  Jones film is currently scheduled for  July nineteen twenty nineteen the  previous film was 2008's Kingdom of the  Crystal Skull so that's a pretty big  sequel gap for now keep an eye on  gamespot for updates and try to keep the  Shia LaBeouf hate to a minimum